Welcome to the open source
stories, digital archive, or
FOSSDA.
Open source has changed the world.
And it's changed the world greatly
for the better.
It's a movement that's been going
on for quite a while now, and it
didn't start because of a
government, or a company, or a
politician.
It started really from people who
wanted to change the way people
had access to software because
software is so important to our
lives now.
Whether you know it or not, you
are using open-source software
right now, and you're probably
using it every moment of your
life.
And that's due to a very dedicated
group of people who started, and
who grew this movement over many
years.
Because this is such an important
change in our world, and because
it happened in the way it did.
I thought it was important to
capture the personal stories of
people involved in this movement.
What made them so dedicated?
What made them understand that
this was so important?
And so I've asked lots of my
friends, and colleagues, and
people I don't even know to
contribute their stories to this
oral history, so that the
generations who go beyond and take
open source forward into the 21st
century will understand, how such
a movement could have come about.
Now, it's only fair that I tell my
own story and it's certainly not
the most interesting story you're
going to hear, but I was a
computer programmer a long time
ago back in the 1980s.
It was so long ago, we called
ourselves computer programmers
instead of software engineers.
I wrote code in compiled Basic.
Now, for people who are in the
tech industry, that is, you know,
a very lightweight way of doing
computer programming, but hey, you
can't judge, because it actually
worked really well for what we
were doing at the time.
But I was very interested in
software as a result.
And by the way, I got into
software just by kind of talking
my way into a job.
It's not like you went to school
to get a job in that back in those
days.
And eventually, when I went to law
school and then I graduated, I
found that there was all this
really interesting stuff going on
in software licensing.
My clients started to ask me,
"What about these open source
licenses?" And they were really
something new.
They were not like anything anyone
had seen before.
And for the most part, they
weren't really written entirely by
lawyers or much like normal
software licenses.
Most of the people I worked with
at the time had the attitude of,
well, you know, you can't use this
stuff.
We don't understand it.
You don't know where it's been.
It's kind of like when your mother
says, "Don't put that in your
mouth.
You don't know where it's been."
And but my clients kept asking me
about it, and I thought that
instead of the answer just being,
"No", which was the answer most
lawyers were giving it the time, I
had to say, "Yes, if..."
And so I started trying to figure
out how to do that and there
wasn't much out there.
Not a lot of information out
there.
And so I actually started creating
some of the information.
And I found it was just an
absolutely fascinating thing.
I mean, people get into the law
for different reasons, but I think
actually for a lot of lawyers,
they get into it because being a
lawyer is like solving all these
really intricate puzzles.
And by the way, that's very
similar to what programming is
like and I love both of those
things.
So I started trying to unpack this
puzzle and figure it out.
And it's been so interesting and
sustained me for decades now in my
practice, and it's made my
practice better than I could have
ever expected.
Just the pure interest value of,
it is really what gets me out of
bed and at my desk every morning,
So I have had a wonderful time
focusing on open source software
licensing over the years.
Well, I hope you enjoy listening
to the stories in this archive,
and I hope it helps make you think
about how people can change the
world.
Thanks so much for listening.